Before we start knitting, let's find the
first row of the punch card
with no yarn or stitches, put 24 needles
in work in the middle of the machine.
Start with the card inserted
so the first row is showing.
Manually rotate the card down 7 rows.
Lock the card.
This should align the card to the first
row of holes down inside that card reader.
Test the alignment of the card by passing
the carriage over the
empty needles in work.
The needles corresponding to the first
row of holes should be selected.
Now we need to get some stitches
on the needles in the ribber.
Caston for full needle rib.
Knit a zig-zag row.
Because we're going to
be dropping stitches.
It's critical that we hang
the cast on comb correctly.
With the zigzag row and
the cast on comb in place,
Use the D-slider and drop all the main bed
stitches and make sure they are all
aligned to B position
and remove the D-slider.
This technique also needs more weight.
You'll need to experiment with your yarn.
Your carriage and your
working yarn are on the left.
All of the main bed
needles are in B position.
Press in both part
buttons on the main bed.
Knit one row to the right
across the ribber needles only.
Set your change knob to KC.
Align that punch card to the first row
of the pattern and knit to the left.
The ribber stitches.
Knit needles are selected on the main
bed. Knit to the right, the ribber
stitches continue to knit and there
are loops on the main bed needles.
With the carriage on the right,
Use that D-slider and drop the loops.
Remember, the D-slider only
goes in one direction.
Pull down on the knitting to get
those loose loops out of the way.
Keep repeating this sequence.
Knit left and the needles on
the main bed are selected.
Knit right loops are formed and all the
while the knitting is
happening on the ribber.
Use the D-slider to drop the loops
or you can just manually drop them.
Continue to repeat this sequence.
Knit to the left and the needles are
selected on the main bed, knit to
the right and loops are formed.
Drop those loops.
Drop stitch lace is an amazing technique
that you need to try for yourself.
Don't get overwhelmed by all the steps.
Take it one step at a time and you'll be
knitting lace on your bulky in no time.